das corona virus ist ein angriff auf
unseren körper aber es greift auch
zunehmend unser gemüt 20 monate pandemie
stellen unser miteinander auf eine harte
probe die diskussion über die maßnahmen
die lässt freundschaften zerbrechen die
wut der geimpften auf die ungeimpften
die steigt und corona leugner
radikalisieren sich zunehmend politiker
und wissenschaftler werden mit dem tode
bedroht und der fackel aufmarsch gegen
sachsens gesundheitsministerin
der hat viele aufgeschreckt auf der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
heute wurde auch klar angekündigt stark
dagegen vorzugehen der reichsbrücke und
spaltet corona die gesellschaft unser
thema in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
schönen guten abend ganz herzlich
willkommen hier in berlin ich darf meine
gäste vorstellen stefan mayer ist bei
uns erst mitglied des bundestages für
die csu aber wir kennen sie natürlich
als ehemaligen oder als staatssekretär
im innenministerium jetzt ehemalige ist
alles noch neu im moment neu ist auch
dass sebastian fiedler ist für die spd
im bundestag sitzt als abgeordneter und
er ist zuvor war er der vorsitzende des
bundes der kriminalbeamten und ist auch
kriminalhauptkommissar herzlich
willkommen ihn und ich begrüße lisa
federle sie ist notärztin und pandemie
beauftragte des kreises tübingen dort
hat sie zu beginn der pandemie eine sehr
erfolgreiche test strategie entwickelt
und herzlich willkommen professor raj
kollmorgen erst soziologe und prorektor
am institut für eine hochschule zittau
und
görlitz und er war auch mitglied in der
kommission der bundesregierung zu 30
jahren deutscher einheit herzlich
willkommen herr fiedler die
pressekonferenz nach der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist eben zu
ende gegangen mit bundeskanzler chance
da ging es natürlich auch wieder um
corona und dort hat bundeskanzler scholz
das wiederholt was er in den letzten
tagen immer gesagt hat nämlich unsere
gesellschaft ist nicht gespalten seiner
meinung nach wie sehen sie es die
formulierung trifft den nagel auf den
kopf und ist auch kein widerspruch zu
dem was ihr jetzt in der anmoderation
schon an getextet haben ich würde es
vielleicht mit einer parallele sagen wir
würden ja aufgrund des existierenden
rechtsextremismus oder islamismus also
aufgrund anderer extremistischer
strömungen auch nicht auf die idee
kommen zu sagen die gesellschaft sei
gespalten was ich damit sagen will ich
glaube wir müssen durchaus aufpassen
dass wir auf der einen seite über einen
sehr kleinen sehr radikalen teil der
gesellschaft sprechen über den wir
vielleicht gleich nochmal detaillierter
sprechen können und über die frage dass
noch bestimmte leute unsicher sind sich
impfen zu lassen das ist durchaus ein
unterschied glaube ich und ich glaube
darauf wollte er hinweisen und ich
glaube es gibt sehr sehr viele indizien
und bestätigung dass das auch
tatsächlich so ist die mehrheit die
masse die absolute masse dieser
gesellschaft hält zusammen und ist da
glaube ich sehr sehr einig manche sind
unsicher und das ist ein unterschied zu
den ganz radikalen und zu den
extremisten
ja mal wie sehen sie es ist die
gesellschaft gespalten ich bin der
meinung die gesellschaft ist gespalten
und ich glaube dass kanzler scholz sich
da auch die dinge etwas schön redet
wenn man sich vor augen führt wie haben
nach über 15 millionen erwachsene in
deutschland die nicht geimpft sind und
dann muss uns dies natürlich vor augen
führen dass wir nach wie vor
einen großen bedarf haben die
überzeugung zu mehren sich impfen zu
lassen und natürlich ist der kreis derer
die radikal sind die auf die straßen
gehen die wir jetzt in sachsen einen
fackelmarsch vor dem privathaus der der
sächsischen gesundheitsministerin
veranstalten relativ klein aber wir
haben nach wie vor weit ins bürgerliche
lager hinein gehend eine große
impfskepsis eine impf abneigung und das
in zwei teilweise familien das in zwei
teilweise vereine das spaltet natürlich
unsere gesellschaft und ich glaube man
macht einen fehler wenn man sich die
dinge hier schön redet wir müssen
natürlich die schweigende mehrheit und
wir haben jetzt mittlerweile eine
impfquote von folge impften von
annähernd 70 prozent 72 prozent haben
zumindest eine impfung vielleicht
stärker noch mobilisieren auch dafür zu
werben bei denen die sich impfen können
dürfen aber bisher noch nicht geimpft
haben eben dieses zu tun und ich
befürchte sehr wohl dass die
radikalisierung in unserer gesellschaft
weiter zunimmt ich möchte ihnen nicht
das wort reden aber wir hatten ein
eigenes sehen in wien oder auch in den
niederlanden mit denen es auch
gewalttätige ausschreitungen gab von
impfgegnern von
verschwörungstheoretikern machen in
einem tankstellenangestellte möchte dies
natürlich beileibe nicht in deutschland
sehen aber es ist auch nicht
ausgeschlossen
tja was soll ich in einen atemzug
miteinander das ist der unterschied auf
den ich gerade hinweisen wollte
diejenigen die sich noch impfen lassen
ich hab das neulich und im zentrum in
meinem wahlkreis besucht und
festgestellt dass ein erheblicher anteil
derjenigen die jetzt in den
warteschlangen noch stehen leute sind
die aus unsicherheit jetzt gerade sich
aktuell noch erstimpfungen holen und ich
glaube wir sollten diesen teil ertönen
und wie eine ein ende hat und co
waren zugelassen sie erstmal noch kurz
unsere anderen beiden gäste für wort
kommen damit wegens einmal da wird er
hier wissen wer wo steht und dann können
wir direkt weiter diskutieren federle
wie sehen sie ist en vogue wie machen
sie ist welche erfahrungen haben sie wo
in tübingen ist es da so dass man merkt
da gibt es starke polarisation
also natürlich haben wir auch das
problem dass es menschen gibt die
einfach angst haben vor der impfung oder
sich unsicher sind und es gibt natürlich
auch welche die sagen corona gibt es
nicht oder ich kann das mit vitaminen im
griff kriegen oder ich habe ein gutes
immunsystem oder je nachdem ich glaube
auch nicht dass es wirklich so eine
spaltung der gesellschaft die spaltung
würde für mich bedeuten dass wir 50 50
am oder 40 60 das verhältnis haben wir
nicht und wir haben anteil der menschen
die tatsächlich völlig dagegen sind aber
das ist die minderheit und die mehrheit
hat sich den crooner maßnahmen gefügt
und hat auch die entscheidungen der
politik mitgetragen
eine starke starken widerstand gibt es
in sachsen herr kollmorgen von dort sind
sie zugeschaltet da gibt es auch die
höchsten instanz zahlen ist sachsen
gespalten als land
ich finde man sollte mal versuchen das
insofern ein bisschen zu orten denn es
kommt darauf an dass wir unter spaltung
verstehen also man kann einen sehr
weiten begriff von spaltung brauchen
dann würde das reisen überall da wo es
wirklich starke soziale ungleichheiten
gibt die von menschen als bedrohlich
jedenfalls von einer beachtlichen anzahl
als bedrohlich empfunden werden von die
die tendenz haben konfliktlinien in der
gesellschaft nicht nur zu definieren
sondern konflikte auch eskalieren zu
lassen dass wir es dann mit einer
spaltung zu tun haben man kann aber auch
ein relativ weichen begriff engen
begriff entschuldigung begriff wählen
und dann wäre spaltung erst dann gegeben
wenn die gesellschaft kurz davor es
auseinander zu also wenn es wirklich
verhärtete frontlinien wenn man so will
gibt die die gesamte integration einer
gesellschaft in frage stellen und
deswegen glaube ich dass man die beiden
positionen von herrn meyer und herrn
fischer durchaus verknüpfen kann
insofern auch die ansage die position
des neuen bundeskanzlers also wenn man
einen solchen begriff wählt dann kann
man sagen die bundesrepublik ist nicht
gespalten also nicht gespalten wie wir
das bei anderen ländern denken sie an
afghanistan oder selbst so ein grenzfall
wie die vereinigten staaten unter tram
dass wir es mit einer solchen
gesellschaft bei uns in der
bundesrepublik nicht zu tun haben aber
richtig ist auch dann würde ich an meier
recht geben dass wir konfliktlinien
haben und das ist durchaus eine
beachtliche zahl gibt und in sachsen es
die in der tat besonders groß an
menschen wie nicht nur nicht aufgeklärt
sind und sich nicht hinreichend
informiert fühlen und soll ich sagen
auch mit händen zum impfen getragen
werden müssen sondern es gibt auch einen
beachtlichen prozentsatz der sich
absichtsvoll
gegenüber dem staat positioniert der
davon ausgeht dass das eine zumutung ist
dass es ein über griffiger staat es die
dagegen protestieren wie also die stadt
aktie autorität in frage stellen und
wir wissen ist dass unter anderem zu den
ereignissen geführt hat die sie gerade
angesprochen haben ich glaube es lohnt
sich darüber noch mal zu reden weil
letzter satz weil das nicht nur ein
bezug hat auf die pandemie und das
impfen sondern generell mit einer
skepsis einer distanz und einer
entfremdung von unserem politischen
system zu kommen viele würden sie dem
zustimmen ist dass wir kann man es
solche vergleichen auch mit
entwicklungen die wir in der in der
während der flüchtlings zeit gesehen
haben dass menschen sich auf einmal
radikalisieren das jetzt ganz viel
ablehnen würde aus einer anderen
richtung kommt dass das phänomen
beschreiben und dann mich der
vermittelnde position anschließen an der
stelle weil ich dem absolut zustimmung
schon seit mehreren wochen versuchen
darauf hinzuweisen dass wir nach meiner
festen überzeugung hier einen neuen
eigenen extremismus haben mit starken
überschneidungen und zum
rechtsextremismus sowohl personenbezogen
als auch teilweise natürlich was das
anstacheln angeht was die mythen angeht
die bedient werden und nach meiner
festen überzeugung wird er uns erhalten
bleiben selbst wenn wir in einer zu
einem zeitpunkt nicht mehr hoffentlich
dann dominant über eine pandemie zu
diskutieren haben weil ich glaube dass
die entsprechenden die stabilisierenden
erzählungen die diesen ideologie kern
ausmachen austauschbar sind und insoweit
haben sie glaube ich recht weil wir
diesen mechanismus in der vergangenheit
schon häufiger kann also wir kannten ihn
nach den flüchtlingswellen bekannten ihn
aber auch schon in der finanz- und
euro-krise und erinnern uns natürlich an
eine partei die hier glaube ich ja meyer
und mich an der stelle sehr vereint die
nämlich rechts außen im parlament sich
befindet und mit wirklich unfassbaren
und unsäglichen erzählungen
begrifflichkeiten wir erinnern uns an
die letzte plenardebatte und hörten
worte von terror und vergewaltigung im
umfeld von anti corona maßnahmen das ist
das verbindende element und ich will auf
den neuen punkt hier an der stelle nur
noch ein satz hinweisen was ich glaube
was uns bedrücken sollte ist dass wir
hier zusätzlich jetzt personen haben die
wir klassischerweise eher der mitte der
gesellschaft zu orten würden auch was
bildungs und akademisierung gerade
angeht leute die es vermeintlich
irgendwie besser wissen und die sich in
diese kanäle hineinziehen lassen und die
sich insoweit in der tat zunehmend
radikalisieren hermann ja das ist
natürlich jetzt auch alles schon
passiert in der zeit als sie noch
staatssekretär im innenministerium waren
wo es um punkt wo sie sagen wir wie
haben sie darauf reagiert wie haben sie
das wahrgenommen diese entwicklung dass
es und würden sie dem zustimmen dass es
nicht unbedingt und corona oder
schimpfen geht sondern dass sozusagen
eine ablehnung des staates an sich ist
ich glaube dass das sehr viel ineinander
greift zum einen glaube ich kann man
nicht nur dann von einer spaltung der
gesellschaft sprechen wenn die die
verteilung 50 50 ist oder 60 40 aber ich
habe ja auch erwähnt aus meiner sicht
geht diese ablehnung der korona
maßnahmen des impfens in das bürgerliche
lager hinein natürlich ist da ein harter
kern teilweise auch an rechtsextremisten
und es stimmt natürlich auch was ihr
feature sorgt dass im parlamentarischen
betrieb die afd sich versucht auch diese
querdenker szene diese esoterische
verschwörungstheoretiker szene zu nutze
zu machen aber wir müssen da hab ich
schon offen konstatieren diese
impfskepsis oder auch diese wie sie
zurecht aussagen diese ablehnung
staatlicher maßnahmen geht aus meiner
sicht weit über die hardcore
rechtsextremismus szene in deutschland
hinaus weiter auch ins bürgerliche lager
ich bin selbst auch immer wieder
überrascht teilweise gerade auch bei
besser bedienen bei uns stellen dann
hätte es ja auch in bayern ist die
impfquote auch nicht hoch also wie aus
ihrem wald und wir haben auch bei uns
leider sehr hohe inzidenz fertig gehabt
die impfquoten auch bei anderen
impfungen wie beispielsweise gegen
masern sind offenkundig gerade in
südostbayern traditionell eher niedrig
erklären sie das ja das ist vielleicht
auch so etwas bayerische mentalität dass
man staatliche dirigistische maßnahmen
egal ob sie aus münchen oder aus berlin
kommen eher mal ablehnt oder ihnen
skeptisch gegenübersteht
es ist es ist auf jeden fall etwas was
beunruhigend ist deswegen bin ich ja der
meinung man kann sich nicht so leicht
machen nur zu sagen na ja wir haben da
eine rechtsextremistische szene die
jetzt hier auf dieses thema auf springt
sondern deswegen rät spreche ich schon
von einer spaltung der gesellschaft geht
dies durchaus tiefer und es knüpft auch
an weil sie die die die flüchtlingskrise
oder die migrations krise
2015/2016 erwähnt haben weil der
personenkreis der sich hier
ablehnend gegenüber staatlichen
maßnahmen zeigt aus meiner sicht
teilweise sehr identisch ist was wie wo
was die die migrations krise angelangt
und jetzt eben die korona pandemie frau
federle sie waren in der zeit als viele
flüchtlinge zu uns kam ja auch schon
sehr aktiv da haben sie sich sehr
eingesetzt würden sie es in eine
parallele da ziehen würden sie sagen es
ist eine ähnliche
der haltung von menschen dass sie dinge
auf einmal ablehnen obwohl sie am anfang
eher eine solidarität ja auch gab
ich glaube das kann man so nicht
vergleichen ich glaube ein teil der
menschen ist sicher einfach radikal und
radikalisiert sich auch aber ich bin
nach wie vor davon überzeugt dass ein
größerer teil der menschen einfach angst
hat vor der impfung bzw
das gefühl hat dass es nicht alles immer
total transparent läuft und da rede ich
jetzt einfach mal von der praxis ich
habe jeden tag patienten die mich mit
dem thema konfrontieren ich würde das
ganz deutschland angeschrieben
ich habe massenhaft mails in denen mich
leute um rat fragen und wir erzählen
dass daraus hat sich dann nicht so
auskennt oder das nicht so genau weiß
ich bekomme von sehr vielen menschen
auch nebenwirkungen der impfung mit die
die zumindest im umkreis irgendwie
kommuniziert werden und ich glaube da
müssen wir ganz dringend daran arbeiten
dass wir da eine deutlich höhere
transparenz auch bringen das heißt dass
wir den menschen klar kommunizieren
natürlich gibt es auch nebenwirkungen
das ist berechtigt ja es gibt thrombosen
lungenembolien oder sonst was das gibt
es alles aber die frage ist und das
müsste man merke und viel genauer
definieren und dann müsste auch die die
sagen wir mal paul-ehrlich-institut usw
noch klare klarere zahlen kommunizieren
die frage ist was ist starker natürlich
ist die gefahr viel viel hört dass ich
mich durch corona infiziere und daran
schwer kranke oder sterbe oder long
kogit kriege als dass ich durch eine
impfung lungenembolie bekomme nur genau
das wird einige nicht so in dieser form
kommuniziert und ich finde sowieso dass
wir da noch viel genauer nachschauen
müssten auch um die leute es gibt
tatsächlich menschen die gefährdet sind
ja und inzwischen schmeißen viele dass
alle durcheinander und sagen ich hatte
meine thrombose ich bin gefährdet ich
habe asthma ich bin gefährdet und so und
da ist noch eine ganz große lücke wo man
einfach hinterher sein müsste sagt ihnen
noch ein beispiel ich war vor zwei
wochen oder so bei einem befreundeten
gastwirt der mich um hilfe gebeten hat
weil sein personal
14 leute sich überhaupt nicht an impfen
lassen ich habe mit denen geredet ich
habe mir die mühe gemacht und die sind
zum impfen gekommen ja sie haben sie
überzeugt sie keine radikale also man
kann sie überzeugen sagen sie das hat
sich auch der neue bundeskanzler
vorgenommen der hat heute auf der auf
der pressekonferenz nach der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
auch noch mal sehr ans impfen appelliert
und dann alle bürgerinnen und bürger
hörmanns das eben an
ich fühle mich auch als regierungschef
als kanzler derjenigen die skeptisch
sind oder bisher nicht dazu gekommen
sind oder noch nicht überzeugt waren
dass sie sich impfen lassen und
versuchen natürlich indem ich eine klare
haltung einnehme zu sagen bitte lasst
euch kämpfen dass das funktion
gesundheit für die eurer liebsten für
alle dienen die kennt und auch für uns
alle denn wir sind dann haben wir ja
auch solidarität schuldig damit wir eine
gute zukunft haben herr kohl morgen kann
so etwas überzeugend wenn der
bundeskanzler sagt ich fühle mich für
alle zuständig und ich appelliere noch
mal sehr stark an alle sich impfen zu
lassen würde das skeptiker in sachsen
überzeugen
wahrscheinlichkeit ist relativ gering
denn solche wünsche und appelle hören
wir jetzt ja seit
weit über einem halben jahr also seitdem
der impfstoff ist wirklich ganz breit
zur verfügung steht oder die
verschiedenen wirkstoffe ich finde es
aber trotzdem richtig dass der
bundeskanzler dass so vorträgt und
artikuliert weil wir ja auf die menschen
zugehen müssen weil wir weiter sie
adressieren müssen und da bin ich ganz
bei federn beide siehe auch brauchen und
weil es ja nicht allein darum gehen kann
mit zwangsmaßnahmen des staates die
impfkampagne zu organisieren ich glaube
da sind wir uns alle einig sondern es
geht darum die anzusprechen und zu weit
es geht sie mitzunehmen und ich bin auch
ganz bei ihnen
wenn sie sagen dass es viele gibt die
tatsächlich verunsichert sind und die
nach wie vor sich im schlecht informiert
fühlen die ängste haben die in den
social media kanälen unterwegs sind also
viele von denen über die wir jetzt
sprechen schauen sich solche sendungen
wie wir sie gerade zusammen unternehmen
nicht mehr an sondern sie bewegen sich
in denen kann gegen den social media
kanälen in diesem berühmten ächtung
kammern in denen meinung in alternative
meinungen expertenmeinung kaum zu
polieren sorgen dass mal so
und die zu erreichen und direkt auch zu
ihnen hin zu gehen ich glaube dass die
staatlichen institutionen und auch wir
als gesellschaft dadurch aus dem
bringschuld haben ob das reicht wird man
allerdings aber es war wie erreicht man
sie denn dann also das ist ja dann
schwierig wenn man also wie schafft man
das dann wenn sie so fest gefertigte
weltbild.de haben und eigentlich nur
noch in ihren eigenen also sich ihre
feste meinung nur noch immer wieder
bestätigen lassen aber deswegen sage ich
den versuch wie mann starb man muss
darauf hingewiesen er kann nur darin
bestehen dass man zu ihnen hin geht also
man muss tatsächlich in die kleinen orte
gehen die kleinstädte man muss an die
orte gehen wo sie unterwegs sind in die
einkaufszentren also das was jetzt noch
offen hat man muss die arbeitsstätten
gehen und muss da angebote unterbreiten
und die auch kommunizieren wie ihr müsst
ihr auch okay also er ist faktum dass
das durchaus funktioniert ja frau
federle hatten sie wollten ist der
glaube ich dazu noch melden und dann
hier die herren bitte bitte
ich wollte eigentlich auch noch mal kopf
sagen was ich glaube es war ganz wichtig
ich habe das gefühl dass es viele
menschen gibt wo die auswärts auch wenig
zeit haben und sich wirklich mühe zu
geben und eine halbe stunde mit denen zu
reden die zeit haben wir im moment gar
nicht ja und ich glaube es gibt aber
viele menschen die bräuchten das und
dann würden sie sich auch überzeugen
lassen oder noch etliche menschen und
vielleicht müsste man einfach versuchen
doch noch zu stellen zu schaffen wo die
leute mit ihren nöten hingehen können
und darüber reden können und der arzt
ihn noch mal ganz genau die risiken und
die nicht risiken erklärt oder den
vorteil von der impfungen aber natürlich
auch ehrlich sagt es gibt die und die
nebenwirkungen weil sonst fühlen die
leute sich nicht mitgenommen und genau
leute die miss price sind die ängstlich
sind die spüren so was sofort das heißt
den musst du ganz ehrlich auch sagen
klar stimmt es gibt auch mal was und das
könnten aber es gibt viel öfters die
intensivstation oder um kogit oder sowas
wenn das stimmt was sie beide jetzt
sagen herr vieler wie hilfreich ist denn
dann eine impfpflicht
naja wichtig ist dass wir darüber
diskutieren jetzt das ist eine denkbare
alternative ist es ist wichtig dass der
ethikrat sich ende des jahres nochmal
dazu äußert mit einer abgewogenen
position das halte ich für überaus
wichtig und ich finde die beiden
stellungnahmen außerordentlich bedeutsam
und ich habe sie eben ich habe es gerade
schon angedeutet stichprobenartig
zugegebenermaßen im wahlkreis genauso
erlebt also in einem zeitraum 500 leute
sind durch sind geimpft worden und ich
habe mich erkundigt wie viel
erstimpfungen waren dabei waren etwa ein
fünftel der leute waren erst impfungen
und ich habe auch da das sind weiche
faktoren können statistiken gefragt was
ist ihr eindruck davon was sind das für
menschen die jetzt erst ihre erst- und
funk holen und der überwiegende teil so
wurde geschildert sind leute die jetzt
im einkaufszentrum hat dass nämlich
stattgefunden die jetzt sagen ach mensch
das ist mit dem testen jetzt irgendwie
zu blöd und dann mache ich das jetzt mal
eben und das ist die masse der leute die
wir noch erreichen müssen und wir
sollten diese impfung das ist der
einzige trennende aspekt zwischen herr
meier und mir so wie ich ihn wahr nehme
ich würde mich davor hüten im selben
atemzug die extremisten mit den
fackellauf läufen hier in einem atemzug
mit denen zu nennen die noch
aufklärungsbedarf haben
das heißt aber dann doch dass die
impfkampagne hat nicht funktioniert weil
wir zu wenig den menschen weil wir denen
zu wenig so die da hingegangen sind wo
viele fragen sind wir haben das versäumt
und weil das die politik versorgt hat
müssen wir jetzt eine impfpflicht
einführen
jesus zu stimmt auf jeden fall nicht die
haben ja durchaus einiges erreicht
werden wir haben jetzt gesagt
wir haben noch nicht die impfquote die
wir wollen und die wir brauchen aber wir
haben im quote jetzt von 70 prozent und
jetzt
stellen wir hier das ich im skeptiker
tief die vielleicht zur berechtigte
fragen aufwerfen in einen topf werfe mit
extrem es einen hafen besuchen ich hab
sie waren in einem atemzug genannt das
stimmt einfach nicht sie müssen da ein
bisschen die gewerkschafts rhetorik
jetzt ad acta legen abgesehen parlament
auch nach dienst im sommer welt
angekommen sind ich habe sich auch in
einer spaltung der gesellschaft
gesprochen aber ich habe gesagt dass die
im skeptiker und der bereich der eu
skeptiker weit ins bürgerliche lager
hinein geht und weit über den hardcore
extremismus bereich rechtsextremismus
bereich hinaus geht deswegen bin ich
natürlich natürlich kommen die erreichen
und deswegen
deswegen deswegen muss ich sagen ist das
einfach eine viel darstellung ihrerseits
der ich mich in keiner weise hier
anschließend kann ganz im gegenteil der
musik in einer in aller entschiedenheit
entgegentreten und was jetzt die frage
anbelangt wir mit der impfpflicht
umgehen es ist doch allemal besser wenn
wir mit freiwillig wäre wären wir dazu
kommen dass sich möglichst viele
freiwillig impfen lassen und da muss man
das eine tun ohne das andere zu
unterlassen was für federle erwähnt hat
ist ja vollkommen richtig und ich habe
auch die erfahrungen gemacht ich kenne
arbeitgeber die haben ihren betrieb
ärzte wissenschaftler eingeladen und
nachdem nach dem vortrag und auch für
nachdem auch fragen gestellt werden
konnten und die authentisch und
fachkundig beantwortet wurden gegen die
impfquote in dem jeweiligen betriebs
signifikant nach oben wäre das doch
besser als eine impfpflicht oder nicht
jetzt kommen dann ersten zwei zum
zweiten schritt also ich bin der
überzeugung dass man mit sehr vielen
maßnahmen auch mit öffentlichen
aufklärungskampagnen impfkampagnen mit
prominenten und natürlich ist auch schon
aufruf wie heute vom vom bundeskanzler
scholz gut und richtig wenn er wenn er
natürlich auch noch mal sehr
eindringlich aber auch herzlich bitten
an die an die adresse derjenigen die
jetzt nicht verbohrt sind sondern die
die die berechtigte fragen aufwerfen wer
sich noch impfen zu lassen ob wir am
ende zu einer impfpflicht kommen das
wird man sehen ich bin der meinung wir
müssen die debatte ergebnisoffen führen
wir werden morgen im deutschen bundestag
ein gesetz der ampel sofort wieder
revidieren das hat gerade eine
halbwertszeit von drei monate drei
wochen gehabt am 18 november ist das
letzte die letzte novelle des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
schlossen worden drei wochen später wird
sofort die novelle beschlossen also ich
hoffe dass zukünftige gesetze herr
fiedler ihrer koalition etwas längere
halbwertszeit haben aber die wir werden
morgen zustimmen die cdu/csu als
konstruktive opposition wird morgen zu
stimmen weil in dieser novellierung eine
bereich spezifische einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht beispielsweise bei
kindertagesstätten bei schulen auch mit
aufgenommen ist wir werden den
änderungsantrag dass die schulen
anbelangt mit einbringen aber sie ist
schon auf jeden fall vorgesehen für
pflegeeinrichtungen für krankenhäuser
und das ist aus meiner sicht richtig
aber wir müssen generell was das thema
impfpflicht anbelangt sehr behutsam
umgehen weil ich der überzeugung bin
dass wenn man es nicht gut erklärt und
nicht transparent macht und vor allem
auch verfassungsfest gemacht dass es
genau das gegenteil dessen bewirkt was
ist eigentlich bewirkt und soll immer
gesagt wurde es wird garantiert keine
pflicht geben das ist natürlich
ein argument für viele radikale und ganz
wichtig frau federer bitte kann nicht
daran am heutigen aspekt reinwerfen ich
finde es absolut richtig also weil wir
müssen uns ganz genau überlegen wenn der
anleinpflicht einführen kann das sein
wenn sie den chef von bayern tech
neulich gehört haben er hat gemeint die
nächste impfung steht in drei monaten an
keiner von uns weiß ob wir uns nicht
alle drei vier fünf monate boostern
lassen müssen sollen wollen ja und ich
glaube da muss man mit ihm pflicht schon
ein bisschen aufpassen weil irgendwann
kann man das den menschen vielleicht so
in der form auch nicht mal einfach nur
aufzwingen sondern dann muss man sie
mitnehmen sonst gibt es wirklich ein
problem für viele wie kann man denn eine
impfpflicht überhaupt durchsetzen ja das
frage ich mich auch also deswegen bin
ich mal neugierig was dann hinterher ein
konkreter vorschlag sein wird auf der
grundlage deswegen hab ich gerade gesagt
also es ist ja bekannt dass jedem
abgeordneten die entscheidung selber
überlassen sein wird am ende das heißt
wir werden keine parteipolitische
bindung an irgendeiner stelle haben
deswegen nie gelernt aus um einen fehler
ich erwarte von einer regierung die
handlungsfähig ist und die jetzt auch
wie kanzler scholz angekündigt hat die
themen konsequent und jetzt vorangehen
will einen vorschlag unterbreitet sie
sprechen von den so genannten gruppen
anregen sondern auch dem motto es ist
den gewissen des jeweiligen abgeordneten
überlassen ob er sich den einen
gruppenantrag oder dem anderen gruppen
antrag anschließt ich erwarte von einer
neuen bundesregierung dass sie einen
gesetzentwurf einbringt wenn sie der
auffassung ist wir brauchen eine
allgemeine und das wäre ja nein in der
fraktion verbauen es gibt keinen
fraktions und letztere aber ich erwarte
mir ich warte mir ein statement der
bundesregierung und nicht dass man es
einfach mal so dem stimmt den freien
kräften im parlament überlässt und die
eine gruppe machten antrag die andere
gruppe machten antrag das ist aus meiner
sicht schon mal die erste
führungsschwäche der neuen
bundesregierung ja ja ja das kann doch
nicht ihr ernst sein das haben wir doch
ein thema wie der sterbe bei solchen
ethischen fragen wie diesen hier ist es
doch ist es doch in der vergangenheit
auch schon passiert es ist doch ein hoch
ethisches thema sie können doch nicht im
ernst sagen dass wir bei einem so
schwierigen thema und verbänden hat eine
der vielen fragestellungen gerade
aufgeworfen die doch da beantwortet
werden muss da müssen sie doch sagen das
hat ist doch eine übte parlamentarische
praxis bei solchen ethischen fragen zu
sagen das entsteht aus der mitte des
parlamentes das ist doch ein positives
erwarten und ich ihre worte der muss
auch nicht bei einem solchen ths hat die
regierung miserabel ist miserabel
gestartet wie gesagt
wenn sie
der neuen regierung hat eine
halbwertszeit von drei wochen muss ich
sagen ist nicht allzu stark allein
dieses gesetz ist befrachtet gewesen mit
über 60 seiten änderungsanträgen das
gesetz dass wir morgen gemeinsam im
bundestag verabschieden werden wird auch
wiederum mit änderungsanträgen von uns
begleitet werden wir stimmen konstruktiv
der dem gesetz morgen zu dass einer und
andy erwarte mir wenn es um ein so
entscheidendes thema geht wie eine
allgemeine impfpflicht dass sich die
bundesregierung dazu stellt und dort zu
positioniert und nicht einfach das was
du den zufälligen mehrheitsverhältnissen
im parlament zu überlässt und so das ist
auch mein afrika das von den
gesetzentwurf für eine allgemeine noch
gibt es das ist ja erst noch in arbeit
na ja
also es gibt keinen gesetzentwurf
zumindest hat es zumindest der kanzler
scholz bisher nicht angekündigt der von
der bundesregierung erarbeitet wird das
ist aus meiner sicht ein defizit und
hier muss man die bundesregierung
stellen die ich erwarte mir nicht gerade
schön wie heute nicht geworden ist sei
es eine tief ethische entscheidung wie
das bei der sterbehilfe von anderen
fragen schon mal geübt elementare praxis
gewesen ist und herr meier sagt das muss
per ordre de mufti von der
bundesregierung
unterstelle ich gesagt ich hab' ich habe
nicht oder die musiker war ich habe
gelernt nicht er seine haltung nicht
erwarte mir eine haltung der
bundesregierung ist jetzt für oder sie
gegen eine allgemeine impfpflicht und
sich so durch zu lavieren und das
einfach nur dem freien spiel der kräfte
im parlament zu überlassen und einer
zufalls mehrheit im parlament zu
überlassen bei gruppen anträgen über
dabei war kann die sterbehilfe oder die
debatte über die sterbehilfe nicht
vergleichen mit der debatte über eine
allgemeine impfpflicht gegen eine akute
corona pandemie bei der sterbehilfe
hatten wir zwei jahre zeit das habe ich
eigentlich bei der sterbehilfe das ist
nicht an einer neu was ist nicht das
erste
testfahrt wir haben uns jetzt akuten
handlungsbedarf angesichts seiner
vierten welle die in ihrer dimension
schlimmer ist und dramatischer ist als
alle drei wellen davor deswegen erwarten
wir eine haltung das ist unser
bundeskanzler
eine allgemeine impfpflicht es keine
akute maßnahme sondern so hat es auch
professor drosten ganz gut erklärt
sondern die zielt ab auf eine welle im
winter
2022 das ist die situation die wir
diskutieren das ist keine kurzfristige
unterstellen sie falsch dar also da hat
also einen seite hier die werte aber
völlig falsch verstanden ja lasst uns
hat er eine kurzfristig nicht hätten um
die vierte welle zu stoppen ich würd
gern noch mal unsere anderen beiden
gäste mit einbinden herr kollmorgen wie
käme denn eine impfpflicht an würden sie
sagen dass sie haben gibt es würde nicht
die im oder würde es sogar noch hätten
hätten sie die befürchtung es würde mehr
menschen radikalisieren
doch das ist noch nicht ganz so einfach
also eine kleine vorbemerkung den disput
wir gerade gehört haben wird vermutlich
einige menschen wieder er davon
abgehalten haben sich mit politischen
problemen zu beschäftigen weil wir jetzt
gerade gehört haben
wie man sich auseinandersetzen kann ohne
über die sache selbst sich nochmal ins
benehmen zu setzen und argumente
auszutauschen oder darüber zu reden wie
man darüber redet und wie man anträge
einbringen finde ich nicht besonders
fruchtbar aber
zu ihrer frage frau prettner ich glaube
und würde auch uns ein raten dass wir
versuchen das zusammen zu denken also um
nochmal ein prominentes beispiel auch zu
greifen bei der einführung der
gurtpflicht
das auch so dass wir versucht haben zu
argumentieren ganz große werbekampagnen
die versucht haben den sinn
und die bedeutung der gurtpflicht für
die sicherheit der fahrzeuginsassen
darzustellen also bis in die schulen
hinein und trotzdem ist es auch eine
pflicht gewesen die mit einer
ordnungsstrafe da wird mir weiterhelfen
wenn ich hier die griffe benutzer aber
jedenfalls bewährt war so dass wenn man
sich eben nicht angeschnallt wie das ja
heute auch der fall dass man
ordnungsstrafe von uns geld um die zu
der zeit also ich würde mir ähnlich ist
ehrlich gesagt auch für diese notlage
wünschen in der wir uns ja faktisch
befinden und das heißt ich würde
zweigleisig fahren ich würde auf der
einen seite genau das machen was wir
gerade besprochen haben frau federle und
ich haben versucht dieses argument stark
zu machen dass man zu den menschen hin
moshammer hat das überhaupt noch mal
ausdrücklich unterstützt ja wieder auch
und das erspart uns aber mich wird das
entbehrt auch nicht einer impfpflicht
und wie man das umsetzt darüber müsste
man sich so erhalten aber ich meine es
kann auch ein argument sein zu sagen die
werdenden problem haben eine pflicht
umzusetzen ja ich meine mit dem gleichen
argument könnte man sagen wir dann
lassen wir mal die schulpflicht
abschaffen weil es so schwer ist
diejenigen wieder nicht mehr schule
gehen wollen also der up aufzuwerten
also dass andere wirklich in einem
rechtsstaat nicht das argument würde mir
wünschen deswegen noch mal dass wir das
zusammen denken und ich glaube auch
ehrlich gesagt dass das für die sachsen
nicht nur für die sachsen genau diese
wirkung hat also es gibt diese spieler
schöne grundsatz der normativen kraft
des faktischen
und das meint dass wenn es eine
impfpflicht gegen die meisten menschen
wissen und zur kenntnis nehmen müssen
dass sie sich impfen lassen sollen und
übrigen federle das der fall sein muss
desto stärker wiegt dieses argument
glaube ich also wenn sie wissen was muss
man tun das ist auch eine bürgerpflicht
damit spricht der bürgerinnen und bürger
es tut er werde das akzeptieren und
können das auch annehmen also ich bin da
kassieren rouge et
de la butte ich es ist schon ein
unterschied ob ich von der schulpflicht
rede oder von der helmpflicht die wie
ich vorhin bemerkt habe unter umständen
alle vier monate oder alle fünf monate
sein muss ja also das ist für mich ein
unterschied und es ist auch ein
unterschied es ist tatsächlich ich bin
absolut versumpfen ich rate jedem zu
impfen aber es ist tatsächlich auch es
gibt natürlich auch gewisse risiken das
ist einfach so im leben ja und ich
glaube dass das war ein punkt den müssen
wir ganz klar offen kommunizieren das
habe ich habe vorhin auch schon mal
versucht zu sagen also ja ich habe von
ganz ganz vielen ja da habe ich das
gehört da habe ich das gehört und da man
da einfach mal klar den menschen das
offen erklärt dann weiß auch jeder mein
risiko ist aber wenn ich jetzt guck ich
bekomme doch deutlich höher wie wenn ich
mich impfen lasse und ich glaube da
kommt man schon auch noch einige
menschen gewinnen aber es mangelt es
nicht versichert wären aber viel haben
wir verbergen was aber frau fehler ist
mangelt ja nicht auch an
informationen auch im netz von allem
möglichen wissenschaftlern die genau das
beschreiben also das ist ja nicht so
dass es daran mangelt und ich würde
gerne mal einen anderen begriff
einbringen nämlich die frage nach der
nach der solidarität die sie in diesem
begriff hatte kanzler schon jetzt sehr
eben auch wenn er den sieg gehabt haben
noch okay dann ganz kurz jahren punkt
mal was sagen also eine ganz große
kritik von mir ist dass ich weiß und es
würde ich auch gerne fordern dass zb
nicht jede wirkung nach einer impfung
gemeldet wird das ist so das können sie
mir glauben das weiß ich von meinen
kollegen das höre ich von ganz vielen ja
also beispiel es kriegt jemand einen
schlaganfall der von mir aus 50 ist oder
70 ist auch wenn das nach der impfung
eingetreten ist wird es nicht sofort
gemeldet ich glaube es wäre ganz wichtig
dass sofort zu melden da eine pflicht
draus zu machen auch wenn man im moment
kein zusammenhang sofort zieht aber
alles was in einem bestimmten zeitraum
nach einer impfung an erkrankungen also
nicht ein verkehrsunfall natürlich oder
so aber irgend sowas das müssten wir
doch noch genauer kommuniziert und
untersuchen weil ja das weiß ich
definitiv dass das noch nicht so leicht
und das kriegen halb manche menschen die
die mitdenken schon auch okay also sie
sagen klar man muss die verunsicherung
der das mit was wir menschen gut
trotzdem will ich gerne mal auf diesen
begriff der solidarität kommen und der
frage wenn sich viele leute die sich
dann unsicher fühlen und die wissen dann
die arme angst vor nebenwirkungen
warum spielt dieser begriff der
solidarität und das gefühl ich tue etwas
für die gemeinschaft wenn ich mich auch
impfen lasse er viele warum spielt er so
eine geringe rolle eigentlich bei den
menschen die sich eben nicht impfen
lassen wollen warum ist das nicht ein
argument wenn ich wenn ich den
medizinischen ausführung und erfahrungen
gerade folge dann hat es eben viel mit
sorgen und ängsten und unsicherheit zu
tun glaube ich deswegen würde ich den
begriff vertrauen und misstrauen noch
mal intensiver mit einbringen ich glaube
das ist ein punkt weil es gibt bestimmte
gruppierungen werden wir eine von
gesprochen die schüren bewusst
misstrauen bis hin zur radikalisierung
prozessen für das dann am ende und
vertrauen ist etwas was glaube ich bei
jeder gelegenheit glaube ich erarbeitet
werden muss und dazu gehört eben auch
dass man offen damit umgeht dass es
natürlich nebenwirkungen gibt aber man
muss eben das risiko und nutzen
verhältnis ganz ganz stark in den
vordergrund stellen und muss eben dafür
werben ich hatte auch einen tag etwas
fieber so und ich fühle mich war das
aber auch positiv weil ich wusste mein
körper hat jetzt darauf reagiert und ich
bin jetzt gebucht hat wird dadurch
sicher war und zum thema vertrauen
gehört eben auch um jetzt etwas
verbindendes nochmal mit hinzukriegen
dass selbst nach parlamentarischen
streit der ja dazu gehört wir bei dieser
frage glaube ich ohne dass sich ihre
stadt los weiß aber ich glaube sehr sehr
einig sind mit diesen appellen und zu
sagen die demokratischen parteien sind
eigentlich da einig und raufen sich
sogar nach vielen streit über verfahren
und soweit am ende sogar noch zusammen
so dass eine oppositionspartei noch
zustimmt das ist etwas positives glaube
ich und man kann dadurch auch für
vertrauen für bestimmte maßnahmen werben
und kann diesen misstrauens kampagnen
stück weit zumindest etwas
entgegensetzen wie sehen sie es schafft
man es diesen solidaritätsgedanken weil
am anfang der pandemie hatten wir das
gefühl also dazu zeiten als man noch
klatschte auf balkonen für
krankenschwestern und pfleger hatte man
das gefühl wir sind also alle
solidarischer wir haben alles gerade
dasselbe problem und das ist jetzt
kaputt gegangen in dem großen tor
ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob es
wirklich so kaputt gegangen ist dass ich
bekomme viele gespräche mit von von
jüngeren menschen auch von von menschen
in meinem alter die jetzt auch gerade im
hinblick auf die weihnachtsfeiertage
sich schon sehr gut überlegen wie viele
soziale kontakte habe ich jetzt bin ich
dann in zehn oder 14 tagen meine eltern
meine großeltern besuchen möchte also
ich würde jetzt nicht von von fünf
kategorisch von fehlender solidarität in
unserer gesellschaft sprechen natürlich
wäre es wünschenswert da gebe ich ihnen
recht dass das thema impfen anbelangt
noch stärker im fokus stünde ich schütze
nicht nur mich selbst sondern ich
schütze auch meine nächsten meine
liebsten mein persönliches umfeld
insbesondere variable personen aber da
glaube ich hat frau federle recht und
auch herr fiedler das sind natürlich
dann die persönlichen ängste die
persönliche skepsis sehr schnell
überwiegt also bevor ich mir überlege
wie ich etwas gutes in dem ich mich
impfen das ist ja auch kein persönlicher
vorwurf überlege ich mir natürlich auch
sehr schnell gefährlich selbst dadurch
möglicherweise deswegen ist natürlich
transparenz in der aufklärung wichtig
was die abwägung von risiken und von
vorteilen anbelangt aber ich würde jetzt
nicht den schluss zulassen wollen also
zumindest nimmt nämlich persönlich nicht
so war dass wir jetzt sorgt vor nach wie
vor wir sind einige steuerliche
gesellschaft wir sind aber keine
unsummen bayerische gesellschaft die
schweigende mehrheit ist sehr wohl
bereit
gerade auch durch das impfen nicht nur
sich selbst zu schützen sondern auch das
persönliche umfeld und ich finde weil
weil auch gerade immer wieder fälle von
von jungen leuten auch eine medial sehr
sehr hoch gezogen werden die vielleicht
mal über die stränge schlagen die sie
vielleicht auch mal nicht an corona
beschränkungen und vorgaben halten ich
habe gerade persönlich den eindruck dass
der überwiegend der großteil der jungen
menschen sehr vernünftig mit mit corona
und mit dem chor ohne beschränkungen
umgeht
kurz zum schluss noch einmal auf die
frage wir haben natürlich diese sehr
radikale minderheit die wirklich
bedrohlich ist wenn man diese
morddrohungen ließen den telekom gruppen
all das herz vieler wie muss man jetzt
und wie muss die neue innenministerin
nancy faeser was wäre jetzt ein erster
schritt den sie machen könnte heute auf
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz wurde
klar gesagt wir müssen der härter gegen
vorgehen wie schafft man das wir müssen
insbesondere diesen
hauptprotagonisten telegramm tatsächlich
so in den griff nehmen wie es sich
gehört also er ist sozusagen vereinfacht
gesprochen auf der einen seite messenger
dienste in der meier und ich das
installiert hätten könnten uns private
nachrichten schicken das ist nicht so
sehr das problem sondern das problem
dass es eben auch in demselben dienst
große plattform gibt wo sich tausende
von leuten eben anmelden können aber ist
derzeit eben rechtlich nicht so
behandelt werden kann das netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz ist eben dieses
stichwort wie die anderen netzwerke wie
facebook twitter und co das ist ein
wichtiger hebel weil in diesem also
quasi ungestraft alle möglichen
strafrechtlichen relevanten
morddrohungen
verabredungen
und was man sich alles so vorstellen
kann was eben was eben ein wahnsinniger
nährboden für radikalisierung ist dort
ungestraft weiterhin und ungeahndet
unkontrolliert stattfinden kann deswegen
ist das glaube ich ein sehr sehr
wichtiger mechanismus hier telegramm in
den griff zu kriegen geht das schnell
naja also auf der einen seite laufen
glaube ich noch bußgeldverfahren ich
weiß nicht ob sie entstand da besser
kennen also ich glaube zwei
bußgeldverfahren gab es jedenfalls die
sind glaube ich noch mal könnten stand
jedenfalls noch offen und auf der
anderen seite ist eben die frage ob man
gesetzgeberisch noch mal ran muss und
wenn man die plattform bot man hat man
dann die meinungen und die die menschen
geändert
weil wir haben also viel zeit gesagt was
ist ihr punkt wo sagen sie gerade auch
in bezug auf sachsen wo wir all diese
schrecklichen vorkommnisse jetzt hatten
wie kann man wirkt diese gegen diese
ganz radikalen was kann die stoppen
also ich würde erstmal an vieler recht
geben dass auch da wir einen starken
staat brauchen einen starken
demokratischen staat kann ich nur voll
unterstützen und auf der anderen seite
brauchen wir genau das was wir vorhin
beim impfen schon besprochen haben man
muss auf diese menschen zugehen und muss
versuchen diese echo kann man auch zu
brechen das ist unglaublich schwer das
ist wirklich das gegenteil von einfach
und es geht auch nicht schnell und wir
sollten uns nicht der illusion hingeben
dass wir dieses problem und der dass es
gibt ja auch nicht nur in sachsen
innerhalb von wenigen wochen oder
monaten oder jahren lösen das sind die
berühmten dicken bretter die man bohren
muss aber da ist politische
bildungsarbeit und da als politische
bildung und demokratie praxis gefragt
und die müssen wir angehen und dann
haben wir auch eine chance mit diesem
problem umzugehen und ist zu lösen aber
das heißt aber schnell kann man jetzt
jemanden der den ministerpräsident mit
mord bedroht
das dafür gibt es ja gesetze da gibt es
ja gesetzt und wir haben eine polizei
und die kann einschreiten ich das
richtig sehe tut sie es jetzt auch in
sachsen frau fehler der seligen also die
wii arbeitet polizei das tatsächlich tut
ich habe nämlich das gleiche problem ich
bin massiv bedroht worden und
ich krieg auch anonyme briefe und die
polizei hat sich bei uns also beim in
tübingen sehr schnell um das thema
gekümmert und versucht natürlich da auch
einen gewissen schutz aufzubauen und ich
glaube das müssen wir schon machen wir
können nicht aber sagen dass das können
wir erst mal laufen lassen auf der
anderen seite mag ich den menschen die
so drauf sind auch gar nicht so viel
podium bieten also ich hab mich hat
neulich eine zeitung gefragt ob ich mich
daran beteiligen würde noch mal ein
interview dazu zu geben und dann hab ich
gesagt nee ich möchte nicht denjenigen
die offen der öffentlichkeit mich über
telegramm als giftspritzen mörderin und
sonstwas bezeichnet haben auch noch die
benennen damit die videos nicht
wichtiger fühlen oder ob noch mehr
aktivieren okay gut wir sind am ende
dieser sendungen wie ich nehme mit wir
müssen mehr auf die menschen zugehen
noch mehr menschen zu überzeugen das ist
glaube ich das was noch für immer hängen
geblieben ist vielen dank herr viele
herr meier profile und der kollmorgen
und vielen dank ihnen fürs interesse bei
uns geht es jetzt weiter mit phoenix der
tag hans werner fittkau hat natürlich
auch noch mal die pressekonferenz der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz für sie und
es geht um die impfempfehlung der stiko
für kinder zwischen fünf und elf machen
sie's gut
[Musik]